a recently published report paints an
alarming picture of the state of many
Americans personal finances the Federal
Reserve says four in ten could not come
up with $400 to cover an unexpected
expense and two in ten cannot pay their
monthly bills in full it's a trend that
Lindsay Stanberry hopes to change she is
the author of the new book refinery29
money diaries everything you've ever
wanted to know about your finances and
everyone else's the book is based on
refinery29 s popular money diary series
where women publicly track all of their
expenses for one week for everyone to
see and pick apart money Diaries is
published by touchstone an imprint of
Simon & Schuster a division of CBS
Lindsay Stanbury is also the founding
editor of the work and money section at
refinery29 a digital media company good
morning love the book I was crackling
throughout no idea finances could be so
fun thank you really talk about how
women tend to feel uncomfortable talking
about money I can relate to that why do
you think that is you know I think it's
still really awkward it's still a taboo
subject it's only recently that we have
entered the workforce and the numbers
that we have and so we're only beginning
to tell our financial stories and I
think that's why money Diaries has been
so popular and refinery29 and I think
that's why it's so important to be
talking about money and so many of these
stories are very detailed a lot of women
have really put it all out there
yourself included why did you think it
was important to talk about your
financial issues I thought it was really
important because so many of the women
that I interviewed in the book shared so
much there's a woman who has breast
cancer and your health insurance there
was a lesbian couple who talked about
trying to conceive but not having the
finances to afford to do so so these
women were so generous with their
stories that it was important for me to
tell mine but I'm also not a financial
expert I've been learning this along
with our readers and so sharing my story
the things that I struggle with the
areas that I've been successful in I
think gives an easier entry way into
talking about money and one of the
biggest misconceptions about money and
you note this as well is that people
find it so intimidating right they think
that it's so hard you argue the opposite
that it's not actually that hard I don't
think it's hard I think that there are
areas that are difficult there are areas
that are awkward there are spaces where
you're gonna have to take some time and
do some research but I say in the
beginning of the book I was bad at math
in high school I was very creative I
didn't ever think that I would be
writing about personal finance for a
living it's kind of crazy but it isn't
hard and it's so empowering when you
have you know when you take control and
you really know and understand your
money and it's a game changer
what's the point of the thing you point
out I mean people sometimes if they have
debt they're they're ashamed evidence or
the way no one really really want to
look at it in the face one of the things
I found interesting is that it's women
who actually hold most of the
outstanding student loan debt in this
country about nine hundred billion
dollars worth $27,000 is the average
debt how do you how do you wrap your
arms around that it's really hard I mean
and it's not surprising either right we
have a gender wage gap so we're being
paid less than men but we're also going
to college and greater numbers than them
so there's a few things I think that
there's a lot of guilt and shame around
student loan debt but ostensibly we're
getting those loans so that we can
better ourselves and if we begin to
think of them as more as mortgages we
can slowly take pay them off it doesn't
have to be a sprint it can be a marathon
but you know there are other bigger
systemic problems holding us back and
with that in mind you know sometimes
these are not problems that you can fix
on a personal level it's more of a
political issue one of the things I
found so alarming was that you said that
75% of those who ask for a raise
actually get one but half of Americans
don't even ask I know right isn't it
amazing I think that it's scary to ask
for a raise I have been terrible at
negotiating for myself it's only
something that I've gotten better at in
recent years but they really say that
you need to be negotiating from that
very first job offer and you might not
necessarily get a yes but that Leisha
set a precedent so that they're going to
start knowing that you or someone who
expects more and you're making it that
much more difficult for them to say no
yeah right something my father had
always said was to have money for a
rainy day
and you say that is the most important
advice that you could offer is to have
an emergency fund how many Americans
don't most Americans don't we did a
survey recently at refinery29 where we
found that one in four women didn't have
more than $250 and
bangs and that's shocking and it's
worrisome we recommend in the book I
worked with a team of all-female
financial advisors that was really
important to me and one of the women
minissha decor recommended that you have
at least two thousand dollars in savings
and if you think about that that breaks
down to about five dollars a day
and I joke in the book I won't tell you
don't not to buy a latte because I feel
like a lot of the financial advice for
young women is like don't buy that latte
and that's terrible advice so I think
that you know I'm not gonna tell you not
to buy that latte but if you think about
that five dollars is going to go towards
an emergency fund that you can use for
something really important it's so
coarse out at the same time you say
budgets or bull yeah I don't love both I
I don't love budgets I think that a lot
of the advice are on women and money
tends to have like a dieting diatribe to
it and that's not helpful they really
set us up to fail if you're worried
about you know $50 goes to your
entertainment this month or $100 goes to
your food and you go over then you just
feel so much anxiety I actually
recommend people do a money diary I know
that sounds like I'm trying to get you
to publish on refinery29
which i think you should but it also is
a really great mindful exercise I swipe
my credit card at the grocery store
without looking at the total I think a
lot of people do making the taking the
time to write it down can delay a change
then yeah I think you said budgets are
bull and then followed by another
four-letter word yeah I don't say that
on what elevation we get the gist
Lindsay thank you so much thank you so
much having me